depuis bientôt dix ans la russie mène
une guerre sans merci en tchétchénie de
multiples exactions ont été commises
contre la population
les affrontements entre les troupes
russes et la résistance tchétchène ont
fait des dizaines de milliers de
victimes des civils qui malgré cette
élection ne sont pas prêts de vivre en
paix attention certaines images sont
particulièrement dures nora boubetra la
guerre partout comme une marque
indélébile
bienvenue à grozny capitale de la
république russe de tchétchénie
quatre cent mille habitants 94 deux fois
moins aujourd'hui
depuis qu'elles ont repris la ville il
ya maintenant quatre ans les troupes
russes sont omniprésentes 80 mille
soldats pour mater les velléités
séparatistes de la petite république
rebelle
les opérations de nettoyage se
multiplient enlèvements tortures et puis
il ya ces milliers de disparus dont on
retrouve parfois les corps
méconnaissable en tchétchénie quand on
est un homme et qu'on est en âge de se
battre on se cachent pour échapper aux
rafles des ben laden potentiel du virus
le 11 septembre est passée par là opposé
à toute négociation avec les
indépendantistes le kremlin temps de les
marginaliser
voire de les instrumentaliser 23 octobre
2002 prise d'otage du théâtre à moscou
l'assaut des forces russes les 129 morts
le commando tchétchène liquider grozny
27 décembre 2002 attentats au siège du
gouvernement pro russe 83 morts des
exemples parmi tant d'autres prise entre
deux feux la population civile entre 40
et 70 mille tués depuis la première
guerre de tchétchénie en 94
dans les rangs russes aussi aux comptes
est mort plus de douze mille soldats dit
la presse et pourtant un référendum en
mars dernier la présidentielle
aujourd'hui la dîme et poutine continue
de prôner la normalisation ce processus
politique vise à légitimer le pouvoir
des forces pro russes mises en place par
le
l'un en tchétchénie les tchétchènes
réagissent à ce refus de négociation et
à cette situation par une radicalisation
de leur action c'est ainsi qu'on voit le
nombre des attentats qui au lieu de
diminuer a tendance à augmenter
seules taches de couleurs au milieu des
ruines
les affiches électorales du seul
candidat désigné d'avant ce ne dupe
personne
que dire alors du silence des
chancelleries occidentales